first day of the season we're heading
out now try to get on some fish I'm Brad
kosowski captain of the fish hawk
fishings always been a lot more than a
job for me I always had solace to be
able to gleave land and just fish to
provide for my family so we can survive
prepping the flag getting ready for a
good tuna season hopefully the new flag
will bring us some luck
Brad's daughter made the logo I first
made his Matt Matson he's just a guy
that you can take out and you can give a
little orders and he'll do what you want
to do when Brad got the Gloucester he
had called me and said do you want to go
tuna fishing
I dropped right what I was doing I went
right down the boat we got the boat
rigged up Brad is a fish maniac if it
has a tail he has a hook he's just a
fishy fishy guy very good fisherman go
check it out it looks good good here
comes apisto
last season I was first mate on the
wicked pisser Paul's boat hey I want to
solid slow down here we had a little bit
of rocky road in the beginning but then
we got it straightened down we did
really well
got him oh yeah but we came up just sure
to be in the number one boat thanks Fred
next year we're going to smoke them
but now I've got my own boat so Paul and
I will be competitors this season here
polls right here brother we're just
going to stop by as Duty says
hey we're you think about the new boat
the boat looks good looks really really
good man Brad is a remarkable fisherman
each of us have been fishing here for
more than 40 years Brad may have
forgotten more about fishing than 99% of
the people even know we forgot Paul and
I together last year we still won we
lost by a hundred freaking dollars I
know we got is it gonna be hard to have
Brad not fish with me absolutely is one
of my best friends I need the best
fisherman around the season Rick has
very big shoes to fill and I have to
prove that I can still be successful
with a new greenhorn mate
any words of wisdom for me Brad words of
wisdom just pray all right you'll catch
a lot of tuna and you'll be fine that's
what we plan on doing I think with me
and Paul it's really friendly rivalry
because I helped him he helped me we
helped each other and now I have my own
boat and one of us will catch more than
the other who will see what happens we
love you guys and you're gonna catch a
ton you're gonna go guys be safe and
good luck right okay thanks guys
okay okay a beer we get it with the fish
you got it that's good yeah get him up
whoa yeah he's got a nice boat huh yeah
[Music]